je vais présenter c'est adel dahmani qui
est comédien bonsoir série qui avez vous
parlé qui s'appelle une ce point je vais
vous refaire en gros le pitch c'est elle
qui était tourné au mois de janvier
oui décembre janvier et 5 janvier l'idée
remonte d'un peu avant au mois de juin
six années d'instruction bonne et dans
cette série vous êtes un chanteur qui
participe à l'eurovision homosexuels de
régis est d'origine maghrébine qui va se
retrouver plus ou mois embrigadés dans
une affaire de terrorisme et enlevé par
des ch
autant vous dire que en france a fait
grincer des dents
ouais ça me fait polémique alors
première question parce qu'on a vraiment
le sentiment que cette série a été
lancée pour faire le buzz autour de
l'eurovision gilles à se dérouler en
vrai ou faux faux faux
alors pourquoi ben parce que le scénario
était écrit en juin 2018 juste après la
victoire de l'état barcella est la
candidate israélienne et que c'est
revoilà les auteurs sorte de la pub
c'est leur premier scénario ils ont
sorti sa bilal n'existait pas encore en
tout cas il n'avait pas voilà on n'était
pas encore au courant que c'était le
candidat officiel de de la france de la
france ceux qui me connaissent pas
encore cette série vous a fait un petit
résumé regarde vous connaissez la phrase
toute ressemblance avec des personnes
existantes ou ayant existé est purement
fortuite
c'est ce qu'on peut lire avant un film
ou une série qui ressemblerait d'un peu
trop près à la réalité et c'est sans
doute ce qu'on pourra lire avant la
diffusion de la série israélienne twelve
payne ski surf sur l'eurovision organisé
là bas cette année dont le pitch nous
est résumé par l'acteur principal d'un
jeune français d'origine maghrébine
musulmans et guay qui se retrouvent
sélectionné pour représenter la france
ici
révision qui malheureusement malgré lui
se retrouve aussi embarqué dans une
histoire de d'attentats commandités par
des ch alors en france et gay blonde
d'origine maghrébine et qui va
représenter la france à l'eurovision
pour le coup la ressemblance ne semble
pas fortuite
on pense bien sûr à villabassa ni le
représentant de la france à l'eurovision
pour la production de la série ce ne
serait qu'un énorme coup de chance il en
fiction coïncide autant avec la réalité
puisque la série aurait été imaginé bien
avant que bilel ne soit choisi pour
représenter la france
tout ça ne fait que nous servira
effectivement et je pense que oui ça va
ça va susciter beaucoup plus d'intérêt
pour la série alors êtes vous choqué par
le scénario de toiles foïs et surtout
pensez vous que les scénaristes se sont
inspirés de bilal assadi pour écrire
leurs séries alors vous jouez donc un
candidat français c'est pas mal mais
nous on a fait le parallèle dette a été
écrit donc au mois de juin est tournée
au mois de décembre janvier et décembre
janvier il me semble que bilal était
déjà en route pour les qualifications
pour le régler on était en plein
tournage qu'on a appris qu'il était
candidat pour destination en vision est
ce qu éventuellement ça vous a aidé à
élargir le trait du personnage ou pas
bah oui enfin on va donc oui oui et non
même pas enfin on a déjà commencé à
travailler sur les costumes le
maquillage se charrient vais un mois
avant pour la préparation du rôle et on
avait déjà travaillé on était en plein
tournage donc je vois pas comment on
aurait pu un peu il aurait pu
m'influencer après nous quand on a
appris l'existence de bilal on a
vraiment eu des surprises
est ce que vous comptez aller à la
police que ça crée en france ça fait un
peu nouée quand même oui oui et non sire
que je sache veut pas dire non à chaque
fois faut dire choqué non parce que je
vois pas en quoi c'est choquant
maintenant c'est sûr que si on pcci
l'histoire parce qu'au départ les
polémiques et partie de ça on a pitié
l'histoire comme mon personnage étant un
terroriste de neige qui se fait passer
pour un homosexuel à l'eurovision c'est
pas du tout ça le pitch non donc c'est
sûr que là c'est plus vendeur c'est plus
polémiques c'est ça fait plus le buzz
après c'est sûr que là effectivement
will la ressemblance est frappante entre
entre bilal et malléable entoure à dire
allez troublante oui/non parle pas du
l'alpha on n'a pas écrit ce sens avait
choqué ou pas bon j'ai dû choquer très
choqué franchement quand la fiction
rattrape ou dépasse la réalité
par les temps qui courent dans le
contexte actuel je trouve qu'il ne
fallait pas faire cette série
j'entends bien à l'argumentaire ça a été
écrit avant mais il n'y a pas de hasard
ça a été tourné au moment ça peut
provoquer des polémiques
j'espère pas des débordements mais moi
ça me choque je trouve que cette série
est malvenue alors ça donne quoi ah non
alors vous avez parlé après des finales
je garde toujours la cerise sur gâteau à
la fois là bas la fin de l'émission
on a beau qu'on a beaucoup de sujets
encore abordé vous inquiétez pas vous
aurez moi j'ai même pas chanter we do si
les gens je voulais simplement dire que
c'est une fiction qu'elle a été écrite
avant la 10 50 fois maintenant je suis
certain que les producteurs sont malins
et que de surfer un peu sur l'actu comme
ça ça fait du buzz
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit vous-même
dans l'interview mais s'en sort mais je
ne suis pas choqué c'est une histoire
qui est écrite avant et pourquoi pas ne
pas raconter qu'ils ont intérêt sinon de
faire du buzz pour nuit pour une baissé
en france s'est vendu en face encore
voilà ça va être vendu à près de namur
fruits ce que je voulais dire c'est que
les souvent dans l'air il ya les mêmes
idées ja il ya eu l'idée de donc de ce
feuilleton et en même temps on a deux
familles la vie à une espèce de co2 une
rencontre des thèmes comme comment je
suis faire jusqu'au bout on a tonné me
laisse sourdre est juste je peux donner
mon avis je ne sais pas moi je connais
ville allez allez moi je trouve qu'il
faudrait interdire la série alors j'ai
rien contre vous avez l'air d'être un
acteur formidable et je souhaite une
très grande carrière pour moi dans la
période actuelle avec tout ce qui se
passe je trouve qu'on doit faire
attention message qu'ont fait passer moi
le message que fait passer cette série
me dérange un people & baby boom fm et
non parce que je n'ai pas vu justement
[Applaudissements]
justement vous avez déjà vu le mal que
ça fait à nantes
lemelin s'affaisser la polémique on en a
créé pour rejoindre le court pour
rejoindre
on pense à la craie cette polémique et
lexis te peut être parce qu'il ya cette
série on est obligé d'envoyer la parole
eh bien vous l'avez attention si c'est
parti alors moi j'ai deux petites
questions est-ce que je n'ai pas
l'impression de vous être pris le pied
dans votre propre filet en ayant poussé
un peu le trait avec la ressemblance
avec bilal hassani et maintenant avec un
peu tout ce qui se passe est-ce que ce
mauvais buzz quelque part ne vous
atteint pas et on n'agit pas cette
expérience rien jeunes époux c'est le
trait de mon personnage veut votre
équipe en fait quelque part non enfin on
n'a pas poussé le créer on n'a rien
changé au scénario de la série mais oui
on a appris l'existence de bilal a enfin
voilà nous n'avons pas des choses et non
pas été plus n'oublions pas c'est une
comédie c'est tuer son grade
autant mon personnage que les
terroristes de dèche que les agents du
mossad qu'on n'est pas comme des débiles
profonds
moi j'aimerais passer à bilal moi je
connais bilal mais tout ça beaucoup il
ya eu de multiples polémiques je les ai
reçus à la radio plusieurs fois il est
triste ce garçon a alors donné il ya eu
des truites à son encontre
on a eu hier aucun rapport avec la série
donc bien sûr j'ai côté que c'était
compliqué pour lui d'aller à tel-aviv
c'était mathieu delormeau qu'il disait
là il ya une série sur lui à bout on
enlève ça reste un gamin de 18 ans je
suis inquiet pour lui et j'ai envie de
lui faire un gros bisou à mes joueurs
c'est pas il est d'abord c'est pas une
série sur bilal non
merci beaucoup
j'aimerais qu'on remercie gilles mercier
mais il ya contact emile allais vous
accusez le remercie beaucoup encore
rageux jeunes et anciens à qui j'ai
beaucoup d'affection pour bilal et cette
série ne peut faire que du bien à bilal
parce qu'elle ne dépend pas comme un
terrien mairie on savait très bien s'est
beaucoup donné votre éclairage
effectivement on va attendre de voir les
images de la série pour jérémie janot